6 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy sounds like one step
forward and maybe one step back in the
speedway Bowl
last week in what's driving you crazy we
applauded the opening of one of the
flyover Bridges finally making it easier
to get from the north 15 to the
westbound 215 Northern Beltway this week
transportation is doing a three-night
closure of Southbound 15 at the Beltway
drivers in the area may have noticed the
reason for the closure they're
installing the art that's part of the
Project's Finishing Touches
now tonight is scheduled to be the last
of those overnight closures with South
on 15 through Lanes at Tropical Parkway
reopening tomorrow morning at five the
timeline for the entire Speedway bowl or
the I-15 north Corridor project supposed
to be wrapped up by the end of the year
according to my calendar that's just
about a month away buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
join the driving crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com